me.
Amen.
Okay.
Alhamdulillah.
Wasam.
[Silence]
Continuing
in
the 210th chapter regarding the merits
and virtues and rulings and etiquets of
the day of Jum, the day of Friday.
Notice that these are etiquets not just
specific to the prayer of
these are etiquets and rulings. Some of
them specific to the
others more general. So most of these
rulings apply whether a person is
attending Juma or not, whether a person
is
traveling or not, such as these two
narrations here. He mentions one
narration on the authority of Omar and a
second on the authority of
Omar narrates that the prophet
sallall.aii Wasam said if any of you
comes to Jum meaning the prayer then he
is to bathe before coming. So bathe for
the occasion of coming to J.
The second narration on the authority of
Abi is he narrates that the messenger of
Allah sallall.aii wasallam said bathing
on the day of jum is an obligation upon
every pubescent Muslim everyone who is
above the age of puberty
who is Muslim. These two narrations are
both collected by Bkari a Muslim. These
two narrations, we notice the precision
of a Noah here because these two
narrations complement each other and
show a degree of obligation or a
degree of merit for bathing on the day
of Jum generally.
And if you're coming to
Jum specifically. So in the first
narration the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam tells us if any of you comes to
J to the salah of J then he is to bathe.
This is a command of the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam and commands
by their very nature
carry obligation.
Meaning that when the prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam when Allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala when his messenger
sallallahi wasallam when we have a
command that command its default
position is that it is obligatory
unless somewhere stated
that takes the degree of obligation down
from obligatory to preferred.
And so the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam says if any of you comes to Jum
then you are to bathe for that occasion.
In the next narration, he mentions that
this is an obligation upon everyone who
is above the age of puberty on the day
of Jum. Whether a person is going to J
or not, whether a person is male or
female, whether a person is able to
go to the Juah or not, right? Because
many types of people are exempt from
having to attend Juma.
Women are exempt from attending Juma.
Slaves are exempt from attending Juma.
the ill are exempt from attending Juma.
A person who is in the midst of
traveling is exempt from attending Juma.
However, the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam here
doesn't connect the command of bathing
to the salah of J necessarily, but he
connects it to the day of jum. This
means that no matter who you are or what
your plans with regards to Jah are, you
are a Muslim who is above the age of
puberty. You are bathing for the
occasion of the day of Jumra. And that
is doubly true if you plan to attend the
prayer of Jumra. Now you have two
commands. Meaning you are commanded to
bathe for the occasion of the day of J
and for the occasion of attending Jumra.
So we have two separate commands here.
Does that mean that we have to bathe
twice on the day of Jumra if we're
planning to go to Juma? The answer is
no. This is merely a repetition of
command in order to drive home the
importance of bathing on the day of Ju
and especially if a person is going to.
Now bathing for the day of J as we have
just heard from the prophet Sam
he said
it is an obligation
upon every
Muslim above the age of puberty. Listen
to the language. An obligation.
We have a narration
in which
was in Medina. This is after the prophet
passed away.
He was standing on the member and he was
giving
who walks in the door.
This was during the of obviously
and so
pointed him out as he was in the midst
of the
and rebuked him for coming late.
How was he late? He was late for Jum
because he was not with inside the masid
before the imam was on the mimba. That
is anything past that point, you're late
to Juma.
And so,
you know, a person might say, well, why
is he, you know, pointing this out and
rebuking him in front of everybody?
Because these are not regular people.
This is
the second Khalifa. This is
the great scholar and soon to be third
Khalifa. they are held to a much higher
standard. This is a teaching moment. And
so
in defense of himself, he said, "I, you
know, he had something
going on and he was unable to come
until right now." And he made it such a
priority that he didn't even bathe to
come. Meaning he just made woo for Jum.
And so Omar said, "You're late to Ju and
on top of that you didn't make you take
make
right."
Notice here how Omar didn't tell him go
back and bathe because your is not valid
without bathing. The companions
and who's who's sitting in the masid in
90% companions
So we have Omar
and whoever was there in the masid of
the companions
all of them agreed that bathing is not a
condition of jum
as wudoo is a condition of salah
but this doesn't mean that it's not its
separate obligation
what do we mean by that meaning if a
person doesn't make woo and salah,
right?
We're we're speaking very loosely
here. Then their salah could not be
valid because woo is a condition.
Okay?
J
bathing is not a condition for Jum being
valid.
It's a condition
for the reward, the specific reward of
Jumra.
that it is valid for. It is a
condition for but merely for the the
salah. No, the salah is valid though
depleted in reward.
And so here we see that the prayer is
accepted.
But this doesn't mean
that it is not an obligation. person may
say well you know
bathing is
right
okay but we here we have the prophet
sallallam
saying
the bathing of
is obligatory
who is going to come and tell us or tell
and correct this narration that it is
obligatory in a different way that woo
is obligatory for salah.
And so there is no conflict between
these two narrations as we've just heard
[Silence]
and
subhanahu
alhamdulillah.